I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello.
Hi.
So, lady, you know that the day that this podcast airs,
we are going to be walking the Nimrod's Red Carpet.
Oh my gosh.
It's the day of the premiere.
Today?
Today.
When everyone hears this, that's what we'll be doing.
That evening.
Oh, my gosh.
Followed by a big old party.
It's going to be fun.
I haven't done one of those in a long time.
Me either.
And I'm actually kind of excited.
Oh, my gosh.
I never remember how to stand or where to put my hand.
I have to practice.
Let's practice.
Okay.
We'll do what we do because you have to do this.
You have to put on your outfit.
Yeah.
And you have to have someone take.
pictures of you in different poses. And then what I do is I pick the one very good one. And that's the only
way I'll stand. It doesn't matter if they yell at me. It doesn't matter if they say over the shoulder.
I only know this one way to stand. That's it. I literally, the minute I get on a red carpet,
completely forget all the things I practice and then I stand like an idiot. I know. Same.
Okay. Well, maybe there's a learning curve. Who knows. But before we're at the Nimrod's premiere on the
Red Carpet, we have a really special episode for you guys to listen to today.
In the studio with us is hilarious comedian and actor Bobby Lee.
So fun.
Yes.
And Jenna, you did a television show with Bobby.
I did.
Yes, we did two seasons of the ABC show splitting up together.
And we talk a little bit about that today.
We do.
We hash a few things out from that time.
You did.
But you guys, today, as we're getting ready to walk that premiere red carpet for Nimbabye,
for Nimrods, we are going to be talking all about it because you guys get to see it out in theaters
this Friday, August 14th. Yeah, you guys, I am so, so excited about this movie. Okay, here's what
it's about. This movie stars Mason Tames as Tommy, and he gets a phone call inviting his teen punk band
to open for Green Day on New Year's Eve. Amazing. Amazing. Unfortunately, he does not realize
that this is actually an elaborate prank. So, believing that his life is about to change,
He sets out on a road trip with his bandmates who are played by Kyler Kaufman and Ryan Faust.
And y'all, this movie is produced with Green Day.
And Green Day was part of writing the story.
Yeah, it's sort of based loosely on their early days as a band.
Yes, the stuff that happens to these kids in the movie on their way to Los Angeles
to quote unquote open for Green Day was inspired by Green Day's early days of touring in a van
together before their breakout record, Duky.
So like pre-Dukee, these are the things that happened to Green Day.
The movie was written and also directed by my husband Lee Kirk.
And Jenna, Lee spent hours with Billy Joe, the band, right?
Developing the stories and everything.
Yes, it started because Billy Joe called Lee and said,
I would really like to do a Green Day movie.
They had collaborated before.
So, yes, Lee interviewed the band, and then he weaved their stories into the script.
So I was talking to Trey Kuhl, the drummer of Great Day.
I was just talking to him.
It's not a big deal.
I know, I know.
I talked to Mike.
I know.
I know, lady.
I know how much you're geeking out.
But I was talking to Trey.
And he called the movie Historical Fiction, which I thought was a really good description.
Because it's not a biopic, but there's a lot of things in the movie that are from their lives.
Like, for example, in the movie, the character of Fred, played by Kyler Kaufman, has this puppet.
that he takes on the road named Gravy.
And Gravy does all these bad puns,
and he, like, drives the other guy's nuts.
And in the early days, Mike had a puppet named Gravy.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
And also, if you are a super big Green Day fan,
you're going to see an appearance by Sleepy.
And that's all I'm going to say.
Green Day fans, he will know who Sleepy is.
And then, of course, the movie is also just full of fantastic Green Day songs.
Yes.
And Lee got to choose songs from the entire.
Green Day catalog. They said whatever song you want. The soundtrack for this movie is sick. That's what
the kids say. Are you being hit? I learned that on the movie. They call it sick. Okay. But everyone,
it is really such a fun movie. It's multi-generational. The young cast is incredible. I mentioned
Mason, Kyler, and Ryan. But it also stars McKenna Grace, Ignacio Diaz, Silverio, and Keene Ruffalo.
And then you've also got Fred Armisen, Sean Gunn, me, Angela, and our guest today,
Bobby Lee, who plays Otis the Security Guard.
What a lineup.
Yeah.
I mean, what a group.
And listen, you guys, Bobby is so funny in the movie.
And I really loved our interview with him.
I think you guys are going to enjoy it.
It has some twists and turns.
I was not expecting.
Same.
I mean, we do some real sharing.
We do.
And some real laughing.
Well, listen, before we get to our amazing interview with Bobby Lee, we do have a fan chit-check question.
This is from Brianna R in St. Michael's Maryland.
who said,
Hello, office ladies.
My husband and I are considering quitting our day jobs and opening our own business.
I'm a little nervous about mixing my home life with my work life.
Sometimes it's nice to have a separate space away from your significant other.
And while I love my husband to pieces,
I worry a little bit about us working together and being together all the time.
And then also being mom and dad.
Since you have both worked with your husbands professionally,
I wondered if you would be willing to share a little about
how that worked for you. P.S., and I loved this, I couldn't figure out how to upload an audio file,
but I hope you will still pick this question. I hope you won't find it too personal to share.
Love the podcast. Oh, Brianna, I wouldn't know how to do the audio file either, so no worries there.
This was such a thoughtful question. Yeah. I mean, first of all, it's a big thing to just pivot in life
and start your own business. Clearly, you have to be a very important.
some day job and you're like, I'm going to do a different thing. But then also to take that on
with your significant other. Yeah. You know, this is going to be what you guys are doing. And I can relate,
Angela, as I'm sure you can. Yeah. I mean, we've both been in business with our husbands.
We have. I mean, it's how I met and fell in love with my husband was doing a film. And since then,
we did Ashland Avenue, the play, and now Nimrods. I love.
working with my husband. We work great together. It's wonderful. He's one of my favorite people to
create with. I admire him and respect him as an artist, and he feels the same. And I think if you have
that mutual respect with your partner, then I think you can be in business together. Yeah, I agree.
And I also think something that works well for Josh and I, which I also think works well with me and
you, Jenna, is that we both have different things we're good at. And I'm so thankful for that.
because when Josh and I did all of the baking stuff and our YouTube baking show, he's just so great
at baking and cooking and the recipes and curating them. And I'm sort of like color commentary,
you know, and the two of us each bring our own thing. And I so appreciate what he brought
and he was appreciative of what I brought. So it was easy to work together because of that.
Well, I'm glad you brought up us, Angela, because I thought of us going into business together
as best friends when I saw Brianna's question, because I would say that the one thing, and this is true when I'm doing a project Lee, and it's true with our best friendship, is that the one pitfall to being in business with your significant other or best friend is where suddenly you forget to have the other conversations.
Yes, that is so true.
Because you're only talking about work.
Yeah, and you want to make sure you're still a couple.
and you still have that, all the things that make you a couple, you know, not a business partner.
Right.
And so when we were really in the middle of our cookbook and all of our conversations were about the cookbook,
I remember us being like both at the same time, like, we need to go away for the weekend.
We need to just go stay at a little bed and breakfast and go for a hike and go on a date night
and just not talk work, you know, because that's what feeds the partnership is,
everything you do outside of the business is what makes you want to do the business together.
Does that make sense?
Yes, because we do that as best friends.
And you're really good at that, Angela.
You'll say, I want to have a conversation and we are not allowed to talk about work.
Mm-hmm.
Like, period.
Best friend stories only.
Yeah.
Domestic life stories only.
You said it to me just this morning, because we trade messages every day.
You guys know that, right?
We leave each other voice notes.
And especially when we're both busy running.
errands, you know? And I love nothing more to see that I have a voice note from you, but you said this
morning, because I had left you one. I was like, you're like, is this boring? This is so stupid.
This is so boring. This is the lamest message. And you were like, Angie, I loved it. It was
slice of life. I love slice of life. Yeah. It's important to keep that in the relationship,
Brianna. So I guess that's our advice is find out what strengths you each have, respect those
separate things, learn how to work with them, and then also still make time for each other as husband
and wife. I think that's great advice. I mean, I don't know what it is your planning to do,
but if you do take that leap, I wish you all the success. Yeah, just all the good things coming
your way. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then we are going to be back with
Bobby Lee. Every week on the Moth podcast, you'll hear true stories that will intrigue you,
inspire you and make you laugh.
When I was 14 years old, I had a deeply meaningful experience, something so real that I knew
it was going to shape who I was to become for the rest of my life.
I saw The Spice Girls on MTV.
For Real Stories, Live on Stage, from astronauts, accountants, comedians, farmers, and people
just like you, follow and listen to The Moth wherever you get your podcasts.
We already started, right?
You're recording?
Yeah, we're in.
Can I do my own self- intro?
Or do you want to do it?
Yeah.
I'm a comedian, sometimes actor, and I'm Bobby Lee.
Hi, Bobby.
Yeah, yeah.
And how we know each other is we did a sitcom together.
Splitting up together.
And I want to apologize.
I don't know if I ever apologized to you for not showing up that morning.
Which morning did you not show up?
Remember that one morning that I slept in?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I do now.
Yeah.
So I woke up.
Angela.
Yeah.
Wait, can I ask what your call time was?
Like six in the morning.
Okay.
So you had an early call time.
So it's now 10.30.
Uh-oh.
Okay?
And I'm in my house.
Yeah.
Sleeping.
I remember.
Did someone come knock on your door?
They entered my room, my house.
So he came into your house.
Yes.
That's what I thought.
Yeah.
And then I felt somebody like roaming around the living room.
Oh, that's creepy.
It's creepy, yeah.
And I come out and I realize, as,
soon as I see the person, what time is it and the panic of it?
Oh, no.
Who did they send?
Like a PA or something?
Yeah, yeah, like a PA or something.
Yeah.
I remember the conversation on set.
It was like, they shot your coverage first.
Was it a scene with me?
Yeah, it was you.
You were waiting.
You were doing all your coverage.
I was.
Yeah.
And I came in with my pajamas.
Oh.
I was freaking out.
That kind of panic is just right to your core.
Has that ever happened to you?
I mean, I've woken up late.
Actually, the time it happened to me, stakes were a little bit lower because it was when
I was an operator at 1-800 dentist.
And I had the 6 a.m. shift, and I overslept.
Yeah.
How old were you?
In my 20s, like around, probably 26.
And the guy called me who was managing the call center.
And I woke up out of this dead sleep.
And my home phone rang, and I was like, hello?
And he was like, Angela, you are two.
hours late for your shift. And I was like, yeah, I'm going to go back to sleep.
You went to sleep. You got fired. No, you would think I did not get fired. I was like, okay,
I'm coming. What's an operator? An operator at 1-800 dentist? Yeah, so I call.
Okay, ring, ring. 1-800 dentist, this is Angela. Do you need a checkup and cleaning today,
or do you have a specific dental problem? Yeah, all my teeth hurt. Okay, well, you know what? We're going
to get you in to see someone that can help you with that. Oh, so that's what you do. Do you have a PPO or an
We're going.
We're going to keep going.
Cash.
I'm going to pay cash.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm going to pay cash.
Okay.
Well, there's several dentists who will take you of your paying cash.
Yeah.
So I overslept.
And then he told me you overslept.
And then I was like, yes, I did.
Yeah.
And then I did get up and go in.
But I was like, I'm just a sleep, just a little bit more.
Yeah, you need that extra.
Yeah, go ahead.
What happened when you got to set?
What I remember is us going from being like,
like kind of like annoyed, like, oh, he's late.
But you were not late.
You weren't a late person.
You generally were very punctual and you knew your shit.
Yes.
Right.
So you were very punctual today.
Yeah, I'm punctual.
You were 10 minutes early.
I'm a punctual person.
This is what I mean.
Yeah.
Like, we're on set.
And it's like by 630, we actually are worried.
Like we've moved from just like.
Yeah.
And we're like he.
I could have died.
We were concerned.
Yeah. And so there was like this great release when the PA was like, he's okay. He's coming. He just overslept. We were like, oh. Yeah. We were like worried for you.
But what was scary is at the end of the night. What happened? The showrunner came up to me.
Oh, did you get like a talking to? And she just, she walked this way and I was sitting down. Yeah.
And she put her hand on my shoulder. Yeah. And she goes, don't ever do that again.
Oh my gosh. And I was.
scared.
I would have been scared.
Were you going to scared?
Yeah.
I want to talk about something else from splitting up together.
Okay, go ahead.
I know.
You talked about this time you were late.
Okay.
Should we talk about?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Should we discuss?
No, because I'll tell you why.
Why?
I think I know what you're getting at.
You've talked about it on your podcast.
Yeah, it's fine.
So now you're here.
Okay, what you're saying, may I say it or no?
Yes, you already have talked about it, and I just wanted to know.
Yeah, but not in front of you.
Yeah, yeah, I don't want to talk about it with you.
Too late.
She's been tagged in all the real.
Okay, so here's the thing.
You know, I don't know if people know about shooting things, but there's coverage.
Is that what you're talking about?
Like on a phone incident.
Yeah, so it's on you, the camera, right?
So I'm doing lines with, yeah, go ahead, Angela.
So let's set it up.
We're on the set of ABC's splitting up together.
I'll set the scene for you.
It's like the Christmas episode.
If I remember correctly, we're like dressed in like Christmas.
onesies. It's a big group scene. Everyone's in it. Like all the kids are in it, you're in it,
Oliver's in it, Lindsay, Diane. Everybody's in this, right? Am I remembering the right scene?
Yes. And it's in the living room, there's a Christmas tree. Yes. And I have to stand up in front
of the tree and face all of you guys and give this like kind of like emotional. And you did a
great job. Like I had to well up with tears a little bit and then hold them back. It was like
a whole thing, right? Yep. So there's one camera.
We do your coverage where the camera's on all of y'all getting your lines.
Yes.
And I'm off camera and I'm giving my speech.
Yes, very good job.
Great.
Camera comes around.
Now it's shooting me.
Yes.
And you guys are all off camera.
Sure.
But you're still there because you have lines that you have to say to me while I'm giving
my emotional speech.
You were memorized.
You were and on time.
Yeah.
Do I have to lock eyes with you?
What do you think?
No.
You don't want it.
No, no, I don't think.
What?
I don't think.
So, here.
Because you're a professional actor.
No, just stop.
I'm sorry for even saying that.
This is your podcast.
You can keep going if you want.
Well, I'm just going to paint a picture for people.
So it's time for my coverage and I'm going through the scene.
Take one.
I'm up there.
I'm like scanning the room.
Everyone's looking at me.
Sure.
Everyone across the children.
All the people, they're all looking.
Me and the eyes.
Give me my lines that they have to say.
and then I get to you, Bobby.
Yes.
And you are looking down.
Like kind of...
Playing Candy Crush.
Into your lap.
But I don't know that.
You just...
You're looking down and I'm like, that's odd.
No, it's not.
I'm at 896 level and I want to get 897.
Take two.
Okay.
Scans again.
I get to you.
Now I can see you're looking at a phone.
And my first thought was, oh gosh.
He doesn't know his lines.
No.
I thought, oh my gosh, I hope everything's okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Like a text.
Okay.
Can I defend myself?
Like a text.
Like, oh, no, you must have gotten a text.
Angela, may I?
That's, like, super important.
Okay.
Because why else would you be on your phone in the middle of a taping?
It's a group shot.
Yeah.
It's a wide.
Okay.
Maybe they're punching in, but I don't know.
But from I remember, it's a wide, so why would you, let me focus on Oliver?
Have you talked to me?
I am looking.
And so it's very distracting because I'm like, what's happening with, is Bobby okay?
Has someone contacted him?
But you were mad.
happening.
I remember you being mad.
Well, yes, by take four or five, when I realized what I thought is that you were on
Instagram.
I thought you were scrolling Instagram.
And so finally I had to go, Bobby.
Yeah.
What the actual fuck dude?
That was bad.
What is happening?
Angela, back me up.
I don't think I can.
Here's the thing.
You know what sucks.
You're a scene partner, right?
So it's like, what I give you, you give me back?
So if you and I were doing a scene solo, you would.
get my attention.
Yeah.
Right?
But in a group,
yes, it does.
In a group, Sean?
Come on.
Well, I think you have to know, too.
We did nine years of group scenes,
nine years of conference rooms,
nine years of Steve Carrell being up in front of everyone,
and us just looking at him.
So Steve would do,
even in his reverse,
give you 100%.
Yes.
Well, I don't know.
See, I'm learning.
Yeah, yeah.
There is a learning.
I mean, this.
But there is a learning.
There's so much to learn.
There is a learning curve.
Yeah.
But, you know, I was trying to defend myself.
I apologize.
I still, the reason why I brought it up on my pot is because I remember the shame of it.
Oh.
Well, you should release yourself of that.
I mean, you were forgiven moments after it happened.
Yeah.
I wish that Angela took my side every once in a while.
Anyway, it's comedy.
Let's talk about comedy.
Let's talk about you.
Let's talk about Nimrods.
Okay.
Yeah.
First of all, I have to say one thing.
You're both great in it.
Oh, well, you're hilarious in it.
But Jenna told me, like, from the early days, like, when we did a table read of it, she was like,
Lee was like, I want Bobby.
And you're like, Bobby's got to be in this.
Like, that's how much of an impression you made on her and splitting up together.
And Lee.
No, truly.
It's true.
I'm giving you a real compliment.
Really?
Yes.
Playing Candy Crush?
No.
Angela?
You are forgiven for that.
Okay.
That is behind you.
All right, now it has.
Yes.
But now we...
I've been thinking about it since.
Clearly, I wasn't holding anything against you because...
Yeah, but I didn't want to bring it up on set.
I mean...
Yeah.
Hey, I apologize for...
No, you know what you should have done is you should have got out Candy Crush.
In one take.
That would have been so great.
Did we have a scene?
No, we didn't have a scene.
Yeah, we didn't have a scene.
We're all three in this movie, but not any scenes together.
I know.
Can I be honest with you?
Yeah.
I saw the movie up until I came up.
on screen.
Oh.
And then you, do you not like to watch yourself?
I don't.
So I stopped watching.
Oh, Bobby, you're so funny in it.
I stopped.
Bobby, you have a line in this movie that my kids.
What is the line?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, yeah.
When you mock him.
All right.
Mock one of the kids.
Puberty is hard.
Yeah.
Did you improvise that?
He did.
That's really funny.
And then you improvise, yeah, he did.
Yeah, because he had such a squeaky voice.
He did.
I want to say something about the movie.
It feels lived in.
real. Oh, that's a nice compliment. I agree. Do you understand what I'm saying?
I do. Like, when you watch, like, old Spielberg movies, he's good at, like, like, ET and
and Close Encounters of the Third Kind. I love that. Do you? I do. I do. Did you see the movie?
Close Encounters of the Third Kind. Yeah. Yeah. What's it about, Angela? What's about Angela?
What's it about Angela? Oh, my God. First of all, it's Richard Dreyfus. Like, phenomenal performance.
That's enough. All right. That's great. I believe you know. Yeah. But, you know, early Spielberg,
the houses live lived in.
And if it's not lived in, I can't buy into it.
Yeah.
If it doesn't feel real.
You know, sometimes you watch a sitcom or, and everything's so clean.
Squeaky.
And you can tell it's on a stage.
And I don't like it.
You know, I like it when it's like lived in is what I'm saying.
The production designer on Nimrods, Adam Riemer, was a genius.
Yes.
Like the home, the garage, all the sets.
I've never seen you in a role like this before as a mom.
It's crazy.
Oh, well, you know.
Well, you were on mom on Splageup together.
Except for that.
Except for that sitcom.
Yeah, yeah.
We're on a sitcom together.
Yeah.
But to your point, it's a different kind of role.
And, I mean, I could get personal.
Oh, my God.
About it.
Should I?
Yes.
So I shot this movie two weeks after I had my port removed.
after having gone through all my cancer treatment.
I had my last infusion, and I'd been kind of like living in my house for like a year,
you know, because I was a little bit on my own personal lockdown,
where my life was just about the treatments.
And I had my last immunotherapy infusion early in 2025,
and then I got my port removed, and two weeks later, I was on set shooting this movie.
And from that experience, I had a kind of heaviness in me because a lot had happened to me in that year.
I had a literal heaviness.
I gained 15 pounds during chemo and during all my treatment.
And my hair had just started to grow back.
Like I had just enough for this movie.
That's my real hair.
People have asked if it was a wig.
But I had just enough hair.
They kind of like brushed it forward.
They were brilliant.
And it was such a gift to me to take that and put it into this.
part, this part of this mom who also has a real heaviness to her. She's a widow. She's raising two
teen boys on her own. And she's a little bit at the end of her rope, but trying to be kind of optimistic
at the same time. I mean, I love this woman. And I don't think this is a part that I would have
been offered or asked to play had I not gone through everything I went through. Because I didn't have
it in me. I didn't have it in my body. I didn't have it in my toolkit. Like, I just didn't have it.
And so for me, this movie is really, really special because I got to take something hard that happened to me and I got to put it into art, which is kind of just the best thing ever.
And it was really healing for me.
So thank you for saying that.
It really means a lot.
I just, I'm sorry.
Oh.
I remember you telling me on set, it was devastating.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
I'm so sorry.
But you're...
I'm in full remission.
Yes.
Yeah.
And now it's like, it's good.
God, it's weird to say it was a good thing that happened to me.
But it was definitely one of those moments in life.
It was a before and after, you know?
There's like, there was my life before and now there's my life after.
And my life after, it's been transformative.
I can't, yeah.
But I mean, I feel like you must have had before and after with getting sober.
Yeah.
Right?
I mean, that's a very before-after.
I think it's different, though.
I don't think I was as scared as you might have been.
You know, I always thought, you know, I can always get sober or whatever.
I mean, that's all I needed to do is to get sober, right?
But you have no control over what you had, you know, so it must be just terrifying.
Yeah.
You know, truly, it's really hard to watch someone you love go through something and you don't know how to help them.
And so, and anything you do to try to help.
doesn't feel like enough, you know?
And so you just try to show up, you know?
And so even as you were saying all that,
it was so great to watch this movie
and have seen you through that
and on the other side and getting to create.
And I love the character
and I love the movie that Lee made.
It's really great.
I'm excited for people to see it.
Well, lady, you took me to get my port removed
because Lee had started shooting the movie.
It was a weird thing for us too
because he'd been with me the whole journey
and now his movie gets greenlit
in like the last two months of my treatment.
And he had to be away.
And so Angela took me to get my port removed.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Which was amazing because she's the best BFF ever.
Yeah, we're family.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So you take care of each other.
I don't think I have anyone like that in my life.
Maybe I'm a girlfriend.
I'm sure you're a girlfriend.
Yeah, maybe I'm a girlfriend.
Your girlfriend.
She would take you to L-AX, right?
I don't think so, but I think that she would, for port.
I don't know, yeah.
Yeah.
But Santino, I don't know.
Andrew Santino, I don't know.
I'm not sure Lee would drive me to LAX.
He'll see me through cancer treatment and I'm not sure he's dropping me at L.A.
Yeah.
Or picking me up.
For people listening, L.A.X is the worst airport to try to talk.
It's the worst.
Burbank, yes.
Burbank?
Yes, for sure.
He's taking me to Burbank.
It's fine.
All the time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would go to the Long Beach Airport.
I would do that.
Yes, yes, yes.
But LACs, man.
Wait, back to Nimrods.
Yes, of course.
Will you tell us.
how you got the role.
I got a call from my agent goes, they said you were offered this part.
And I said, yes, immediately.
There you go.
Because I knew Billy from a long time ago during my mad TV days.
Billy Joe Armstrong from Green Day, producer of this movie.
Yeah.
And I used to hang out with him.
I run into them.
I hang out with it.
Back then, LA was different.
Like, I remember going to Baja Fresh and then running into the strokes.
You know what I mean?
You just run into people.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
What was your first neighborhood in L.A.?
It was.
It was North Hollywood, then Silver Lake, then West Hollywood, then Hollywood, and now Studio City.
Yeah, so I've been around.
Where were you in West Hollywood?
I lived above the comedy store.
Polly owned it.
Are you serious?
Oh, yeah.
What was that like?
It was terrible.
It was a human nightmare.
That seems really difficult.
I would come home and be on my bed sleeping.
Oh, my gosh.
Polly, sure.
Yeah.
Dude, I own the house, brah.
Right?
I could sleep wherever I want to sleep.
I go, I pay rent.
Dude?
I pay rent.
But anyway, so I moved out of there because the house is falling off a cliff, they said.
The comedy store?
No, no.
So the house above the comedy store, the inspector came in and goes, you could die in here.
And then I remember a bunch of comics were like, just buy a house.
You can buy it.
So I bought my first house.
Nice.
After that, yeah.
Which is freeing in many ways.
It feels grown up.
Yeah.
And back then you could afford it.
Now you can't.
No.
Now it's crazy. Yeah, now you can't. But yeah, now it's crazy.
Okay, wait, there's one thing I have to tell you. I really want to come see your stage show.
No. What do you mean stage show? Stand up?
Yes.
Dude, yeah, it's just stand-up. I have a special coming out on Hulu in November.
Okay. It's my first hour special.
I know, it's your first hour special. That's amazing.
For what company? Hulu.
Okay, good.
I was listening.
Okay.
But my sons love you. And they were so tickled that I was meeting you today.
They just can't believe that you're in the podcast.
Were they? Are they here?
No, they're at home.
Okay.
But my nephew...
You're a big deal.
You met my nephew on the set of Nimrod.
Yes.
He flew out because he wanted to see a couple days of filming.
It's because of you.
Was I nice to him?
Yes, very.
Oh, because I'm a nice person.
Yes.
Yeah, sure.
Exactly.
He was so excited to meet you and that was so nice of you.
Stage show?
I sometimes get phrases wrong, just a little bit.
I want to brag on you.
I'm going to talk about what a nice person you are.
I hope this won't be embarrassing to you.
I don't think it would be.
Okay, so there's a...
young guy in this movie, Ryan Faust.
Love him.
He plays the drummer in the young punk band.
Yeah, I understand.
He's so great.
I'm letting other people know.
Uh-oh.
This guy, first of all, he's just so good in the movie.
He's so funny.
He's so good in the movie.
So good in the movie.
And he had to learn to play the drums because he's really playing.
I think they all had to learn, right?
Yes.
Well, Kyler Kaufman already knew how to play guitar.
But yes, Mason Tames had to learn to play guitar.
and then Ryan had to learn drums.
And he was really dedicated.
Yeah, because he's a student of acting.
Yeah.
He wants to immerse himself into the role and not look fake.
And that's what I love about Ryan is that he's brave and he commits.
And I know what the compliment is.
You do.
And I don't think it's a compliment.
And I don't think it's me being a nice guy.
It's just that I like bravery.
Mm-hmm.
And Ryan said to me on set, I want to try stand-up.
Is that what you're going to get at?
Yeah.
You said you write a set.
let's set a date and I'll let you open for me.
Yeah.
That's what I said.
I mean, that's fucking cool.
And he did it a bunch of times.
I know.
Yeah, and he was very good.
And that kind of like mentorship, like that is so cool.
That is so cool.
Yeah, I've done that a lot.
But it's like, I just love people that are brave and that walk through fear.
And I'm willing to hold someone's hand to do that.
You know, but yeah, I'm not one of those guys that are like completely jealous or I want people
to make it.
That's a beautiful thing.
Because it's in, I mean,
you know,
in order to achieve success,
you have to help people
achieve the success, I believe.
And people probably helped you.
Yeah.
They did.
I think the Shore family was very vital,
you know.
Polly's mom owned the comedy store.
And she saw me do open mic,
and then she saw me open for her son,
and she made me a paid regular,
and I moved to L.A.
This is in San Diego.
And so they really helped.
And a lot of,
comics helped, you know, and dice clay helped in a weird way, you know. People really kind of
pulled me up by my sleeves. Is that the term? I don't know. But people took a chance on you.
Right? People helped you, no? Of course. Yeah, of course. And this is the thing. Like, this is,
I love that about our industry when you find those other people who are like that. I believe there's
enough room for everyone. Yeah. And if you've got a talent, we've got room for you. Yes. I do believe
that too. And it's like, I'll tell you something, I was plagued by jealousy early on in my career.
I had to have a moment where I was like, what about me? And then, you know, about a year of that,
I was like, this is not who I am. And it's painful to live in that. Yeah. To live in that.
You know, I have to admit that, you know, but yeah, I'm completely different now. Yeah, abundant universe.
You kind of come to that. And I think if you get older. I think that to survive,
in this biz.
And also, can I just say this too,
you're adapting to the transitions of show business.
Like for me, it's like I saw the writing on the wall a little bit.
I was like, I had to create my own thing.
Yeah.
Right?
And so you created this thing.
It's your own thing.
And it's like you're adapting because it's like,
I think that obviously it's transitioning into something else.
We don't know really what it is with the emergence of AI and other things.
But it's like,
we're adapting to what it is.
So it's like for you to survive this long is amazing.
Yeah.
You know, you're survivors.
Well, thanks for saying that.
Yeah, you have to be able to adapt, right?
Yeah.
So what do you want to do next?
I'm going to retire in three years.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Retire from what?
Everything.
From podcasting, comedy, and acting?
You're just going to piece out.
Where are you going?
I want to go to Hawaii.
Oh, yeah.
And just buy a little place.
Amazing.
And just farm.
Yes.
But when I'm never going to do it, am I?
Why not?
Because I say it, but I don't think I will.
This is a beautiful idea.
Don't you feel compelled to be artistic and creative, though?
Like, where will you take that energy in the Hawaii farming chapter?
Okay, so here's what I'll do.
This is my plan.
Okay.
I'll still do my own solo podcast in Hawaii, but more ranting and raving about things.
And then I'll still do local stand-up in Hawaii.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then I think that'll fill, you know, but it's like...
Yeah, but I think that I've been chasing this since I was 23 years old.
Yeah.
And it never seems like I made it.
You made it.
I know, but it doesn't feel like it.
I know.
Okay.
I want to unpack this.
What do you expect making it would feel like?
Well, can I be honest with you?
Of course.
This is the first movie Nimrods where I was in the opening credits.
Yeah.
So thank you for that experience.
I've done a lot of movies before, but I was always in the end credits.
And 52 names would come down.
And they would say, Bobby Lee, Ken Park, but like no one's watching.
My point is that I've been in this business for so long.
I've been on sitcoms and series regular.
So God bless America.
But my point is this is that this is the first movie where I was in the opening credits.
You're on the movie poster too.
I know.
My point, though, being that I'm grateful for what I've had,
but it's like this chasing thing.
I think I'm done with.
Well, that's a real thing to listen to.
I'm with you.
I feel tired of just...
Chasing.
I don't want to be a hamster on the wheel.
I've been telling Jenna that.
And I'm happy.
And I think everything I've done is enough for me.
Really?
Happiness is a warm.
Yes, it is.
I don't know why I did this.
I'm sorry.
Can you tell us more about Mad TV?
What was that like?
But you understand.
When I was on Mad TV, I'd never take an acting class.
I've never been on TV.
I didn't know what a jib camera was or a mark was or any of that.
Yeah.
So you're learning how to do TV.
I was an open micer, like doing just like little rooms and like empty rooms.
No one knew who I was.
And then all of a sudden, you know, I auditioned.
It was a cattle call pretty much.
And then it came down to me and Taryn Kill him.
That's crazy.
Wow.
And they hired both of us.
He was on Matt TV before he was on SNO.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. And then all of a sudden, I'm on a show and I don't know how to do it.
Like, I just didn't know how to do it.
How old were you?
I was 30.
30, yeah.
I was 30 when I booked the office.
Yeah.
And I was like, how do you do this?
You know, I did some commercials, but it's like, those are different.
Yeah.
Because, you know, sometimes when you're a commercial, it's like, you'll see somebody
running by you and you just do a facial expression.
Those I can do.
Right.
But it's like, you know, anything with like substantial lines, you know, it would be
nerve-wracking for me.
Because back then also, there was no teleprompter.
Yeah.
So if I played Connie Chung and I had to do a monologue, it was literally learn the whole thing.
Is that right?
Oh, yeah.
Wow.
And you're looking in the camera and you're like, you have to memorize a page worth of things.
And I remember at one time, one of the producers came up to me and she held my hands.
And she said, just breathe.
It was in front of a live audience, too.
I don't know.
I never did.
in high school maybe did some plays, but, you know, I was in The Sound of Music.
I played Kirk, whatever, or Kurt, whatever his name is, but I played Huckleberry Finn.
Yeah.
Why you laughing?
I don't know.
I just, can I just say something.
I wish I could go back and see you in these productions.
So when Fraulein Maria calls us for the first thing coming down this era, I was in high school,
and I was the only Korean kid in the cast.
And every time the audience would see me, the audience would laugh.
Oh, no, that's terrible.
And then I asked the director of, you know, you're in high school, you're like,
can't we change the lines?
They go, what do you mean?
I go, just to justify why I'm there.
So like, I'm Kirk, I'm adopted.
Or something.
You're like, so long, farewell, and Vita say goodnight.
Yeah.
I'm Kirk.
I'm adopted.
Yeah.
Something like that, right?
It's like even playing Huckleberry Finn, it's like we have to justify why I'm Korean in the
South in this time period.
Yeah, that's where things have changed, I feel like.
Yeah.
For our kids.
I couldn't even believe I even got those roles.
You know what they're like, anyway.
So I was scared, but I'm fine now.
Yeah.
Could I tell you what they did to me at Matt TV?
What?
They made a compilation of my bad table reads.
Do you do bad table reads?
I do.
You're not good at a table read?
I hate them.
Table reads are intimidating, though.
They are.
I think you kill it.
No, I don't.
She does.
she'll get like a guest spot on a show.
Yeah.
And she'll do the table read.
And then they'll give her more lines the next day because she crushed the table read.
Wow.
That's Angela Kinsey.
She's always, no, it's true lady.
They're always like, expanded.
You're like, oh, we wrote you another whole scene.
They take scenes away from me.
The table read.
Yeah.
This is the truth.
I've literally had people go, we're not doing that scene.
And you go, oh, why?
But I know why.
Because I fucked up the scene before.
It's hard when you're guest starring.
It is guess.
Because people have been working together for maybe sometimes years.
Yeah.
And you're like a new person.
And sometimes they're not even that nice to you.
Here's the thing.
I'm okay to table read, but I'm horrible at the chit-chat small talk once we're on set.
When you're a guest star?
Yeah.
Because I assume like if someone's like, how are you?
How is your day?
Jenna knows I'll just say, well, here's the thing.
I think a rat is eating.
the inside of my car.
This is true.
But I will tell this person who's just like an AD who just is wanting to like walk right past me.
But it's a funny thing to say.
But it's just what's happening.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And so those are inside thoughts.
Yes.
And then I watch the person's eyes glaze over of like, oh my God.
I told Sarah Jessica Parker I had foot fungi.
Did you really?
You were sitting there in, she was doing crosswords or something as they do.
Oh, yes.
You were so good.
on that show.
No, I wasn't.
And just like that.
I don't think I was, but thank you.
Stop it!
But yeah, I remember like doing that.
Making conversation.
Yeah, but it was like my, like I'm around a lot of comedians, you know, and she was super
nice.
I love her.
Of course.
But I didn't know what to bring up.
Can I tell you my super cringedged story.
Tell me.
Being a co-star.
It was not even a guest star.
Not a recurring.
What's a difference?
Okay, you were recurring on and just like that.
You were in several.
episodes, but not every episode.
You're in many episodes, though.
That's recurring.
That's great.
You're like kind of part of the cast.
What's guest starring?
Guestar is when you have like one week, one week.
One whole week.
You probably have multiple scenes.
You have a significant, like some part of the story involves you.
And then co-star is usually also referred to as like five and under.
You have five or less lines.
Okay, but I had a co-star role on a comedy.
I had five or less lines and it was on post office.
pre-office.
Oh, what the Nets?
It was Spin City, the Charlie Sheen years.
So I'm in this scene.
So it's Charlie Sheen, Heather Locklear,
Scott Wolfe, and Vanessa Marcell.
So all of these people are like household names,
and I am hired to play their waitress.
But I'm new.
This is my first speaking role on a television show.
You were nervous.
I was in hair and makeup with Heather Locklear.
She was so nice to me.
and then we get on set and we rehearse, but now we're waiting for notes.
And the four of them start talking.
And oh my God, they're talking about like all these tabloid stories and they know if something's
true or not true.
They're gossiping.
And you're listening in.
I'm listening, but I don't know where I'm supposed to be like, am I part of this group
or am I not part of this group?
You're not.
And I didn't.
And so I, before I knew, because she,
She was so nice to me in the trailer.
Heather Lachlager.
I think I'm part of the group.
You think you're a pal.
What are the signs that you're part of the group?
Because she was nice to you?
Because she was nice to me in hair and makeup.
Yeah.
And we're standing there.
And I'm, when you say nice, she said, hello.
She also asked if I wanted some cheese.
Oh, that's good.
That's really nice.
She's like, I want.
BFF.
Yeah, BFF.
Yeah.
Someone came in and said, does anybody want a snack?
She's like, oh my God, could we get like some cheese and crackers and stuff?
She's like, do you want some cheese and crackers if you share them?
What a sweetheart.
Right?
And they're like, I'll take cheese and crackers.
Sure.
No.
So anyway, I can't move.
I'm not allowed to leave the set.
I have to stand next to the table while we're waiting for our notes.
And they're talking and I think I'm in the conversation.
And so I chime in.
Oh, no.
Instinctually no.
Do you feel it?
I feel it right now.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Bobby, you know how you're still carrying around the phone incident from splitting up together.
I carry around my chime in.
on Spin City.
Wow.
I still in my body.
Can you tell me what the reaction was?
Like, do you remember what?
It was crickets.
It was silence.
And then Heather Locklear broke the silence with like a completely kind like gesture, like a kind of like, ha, huh?
You know, like.
But imagine them.
But imagine them when you got the office.
Well.
And then they look back and they went, you know what?
Hey, we should have been nicer to her.
No, it's not that they were.
We should have laughed.
It's not that they were unkind.
What'd you say?
I don't remember.
I just chimed in on the conversation and I realized it was just a record scratch.
But then the very next year, I booked a pilot opposite Scott Wolf.
Wow.
Tell him the name of the pilot.
This is amazing.
Rubbing Charlie.
That's a real type of.
Who bounced that around?
Is Scott Wolf, Charlie?
Yeah.
I rubbed him.
I was a masseuse.
Wow.
And it was like he was a successful doctor.
Yeah.
And he would come to see me as his masseuse.
What is the show?
What is that show?
I was kind of like therapy for him.
But I was the female lead.
I did not remind Scott Wolf that I had been on Spinsonson.
Why?
Because I wanted him just forget.
But you know why you shouldn't bring it?
I think you're in sickness is right because, and I'm going to say this, is that you perceived it that way.
Oh, you just.
got deep, Bobby.
Because we perceive things, like personally, and we ruminate about things.
Yeah.
And it might not even be true to them.
Oh, that's so good.
So I do that a lot.
Like, I'll bring it up, something up, and I'll go, I was so embarrassing.
And they're like, we don't really remember that.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
And I'm like, oh, and then you kind of go, oh, it's in my mind.
And you lay in bed and you think about it.
And you replay it over and over again.
But it's like, you know, I'm.
sure none of them even remember you being in the show.
That's what I mean.
Like, he didn't see me on day one of our pilot and be like, oh, my gosh, the waitress.
Yeah.
Who said that weird thing.
He didn't say anything.
Just like until you reminded me, I did not remember about that time you didn't show up to
set because you ever slept.
Like I had.
Yeah, but I've been thinking about that every day since.
But now you can let it go.
I'm going to let it go now.
Yeah.
All right.
So that was good podcast.
Thank you for coming on.
Of course, dude.
I want to say watch Nimrods.
It comes out.
What's the date?
August 14th.
In theaters.
Bobby plays Otis.
He's hilarious.
I play Otis.
And then, you know, it's really good to be here.
We could do this for 10 hours, I think.
We could.
We're a good team.
Don't you think?
We could go on forever.
Yeah.
I think we're good together.
I do too.
I do.
Oh, my gosh.
Bobby is just so fun and so great to talk to. We talked about things I could never have anticipated.
Yeah. No, that's the great thing about Bobby is he's really, really funny, obviously. So you know you're just going to have a fun time when you're with him. But he isn't afraid to get serious.
Oh, but before we go, Sam, I want to share that you are also in Nimrods. Yes, there's a big crowd scene at the end that I am in. If you have an eagle eye, you should be able to spot me. My friends.
Steve and my friend Samantha. You're at the New Year's Eve big concert. Yes. I just wanted to say,
I don't think we talked about that moment since then. I grew up in a real small town in Wisconsin.
I still have a lot of friends and family back there. They often think my life is a lot more
exciting than it is due to this podcast and my social media and stuff like that. That was one
of those moments. I remember leaving being like, I can feast on this for months. Like this is why I left
my small town in Wisconsin. Yeah, that was so cool. Thank you for having me.
I mean, it was really neat.
And when you got there, everybody had to put their phones in, like, a little pouch.
Nobody was allowed to have their phone.
But I sneaked pictures of you and your friends.
That's right.
Sam, it's good to know the director's wife.
Yeah.
Well, keep in mind, this is the second cool thing.
You invited me to the table read.
A long time ago.
At the Paladium.
Oh, my gosh.
This is my second time being up close in front with Green Day, thanks to you.
And what a full circle moment that you were.
were at the very first table read of this movie when it was in development.
And I read multiple characters.
So did you, Jenna, because Lee just needed to hear it out loud.
Yes, but Green Day was there.
That's right.
Billy just sat next to me.
Also, did you mention earlier, this is the Sleepy?
Copenhagen Sleepy.
That is bananas.
Banana.
That is a deep cut.
I hope I'm not going to get in trouble for sharing that Sleepy makes an appearance.
That is insane.
Do you need to ask and make sure?
I mean, a few people have mentioned it when they have written about the movie.
So I think at this point, it's coming out on Friday.
Yeah.
That is a deep cut, by the way.
It's a deep cut.
That's awesome.
Well, so cool.
Everybody goes to see the movie and let's all look for Sam.
And wow, thank you, Bobby Lee, for joining us in the studio today.
He's wonderful.
I love him so much.
Everyone, please remember he has his comedy special.
coming out in November on Hulu,
and be sure to check him out on his two podcasts, Bad Friends.
And Tiger Belly, they're very funny,
and you can find them on YouTube and wherever you listen to your podcast.
And check all three of us out in the movie Nimrods coming out, August 14th.
Everyone, it is a really, really fun movie to see in a group in the theaters.
So grab your pals.
We'll be there, and we hope you enjoy it.
All right.
We'll see you next week.
See you then.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.